So we have this line
segment JL here,
and we have point K that
also sits on that segment.
And they tell us that JK
is equal to 7x plus 9.
So this distance right over
here is equal to 7x plus 9.
Then they tell us that
JL is equal to 114.
So JL is the entire
length of the segment.
So this entire thing
is equal to 114.
Then they tells us that
KL is equal to 9x plus 9.
So this right over here
is equal to 9x plus 9.
And they say find KL.
So they essentially want us to
figure out what does 9x plus 9
equal?
And to figure that out, we have
to figure out what x equals.
And lucky for us, they've given
us all the information we need.
They tell us that the
entire segment is 114 long.
And they don't
give us any units.
It's just 114.
It has a length of 114.
And we know that this segment,
JK plus KL, added together,
is going to be equal to the
length of the entire thing.
So we could say that
7x plus 9-- actually
let me write it this way.
We could write that JK, so
the length of segment JK
plus the length of segment KL
is going to be equal to 114.
And we know that the length
of segment JFK is 7x plus 9.
We know that the length of
segment KL is 9x plus 9.
And this is going
to be equal to 114.
And now we just
have to break out
a little bit of our
algebraic skills.
So the first thing
we might want to do
is, let's see, we have two
terms that have x's in them.
If I have 7 x's, and I were to
add that to another 9 x's, that
means I'm going to have 16 x's.
And then if I have-- so
this is just plain old 9,
and I add it to another 9.
That's going to give me 18.
And that's going
to be equal to 114.
Now I just subtract
18 from both sides.
Let me do that explicitly.
So I subtract 18
from both sides.
On the left-hand side I have 16
x, and on the right-hand side,
I'm going to have 114 minus 18.
Well, if I were to subtract
14, that would get me to 100.
And I'm going to subtract
4 more than that,
so that's going to get me to 96.
And now we just divide
both sides by 16.
And let's see, this looks
like 96 divided by 16--
we could do it
explicitly, but it
looks like it's going to be 6.
6 times 10 is 60.
6 times 6 is 36.
60 plus 36 is 96.
So we get x is equal to 6.
Now we're not done yet.
We're not looking just for x.
We're looking for
the length of KL.
KL is 9x plus 9.
Let me write that down.
So KL is equal to 9x plus 9.
They told us that right over
there, is equal to 9x plus 9.
We just figured out
that x is equal to 6.
So this is equal to
9 times 6 plus 9.
And this is equal to-- 9 times
6 is 54, plus 9, is equal to 63.
So KL is equal to 63.